las vegas has been dubbed the buffet
capital of the world but as the pandemic
has changed
so much of what we do it's also changed
the way we buffet
and many properties are going to be
making changes specifically caesar's
entertainment
as well as station casinos say they
don't plan to reopen buffets anytime
soon
but one property on the strip is keeping
its beloved buffet going
madison kimbrough joining us live from
the south point to explain
the change in dining experiences
hey there yeah we're here at southpointe
casinos yes
and you know they are really changing
the way they serve but
keeping with the buffet style so you can
see we are here
live and i spoke to several people who
shared their thoughts on buffets
some want them to stay others want a
re-imagined way of serving the masses
one of the ways that you knew you were
in vegas is you went to this casino
buffet
and got a lot of food for not a lot of
money las vegas is known for so many
things and while we have seen live
entertainment take a back seat
another big aspect to the vegas
lifestyle has two
buffets but gaming historian david
schwartz doesn't see them going away
forever
i think when it is safe they will come
back in some form
you know it's hard to say when that'll
be but i don't think you know i think
there's such an association with vegas
and buffets that somebody's going to
want to keep this alive
several properties moved away from
buffet services including wynn
and circus circus replacing theirs with
a food court
taurus dawn kegel hopes vegas can keep a
phase but find a safe way to do it
i just recently went to one where i'm
from in houston they had it set up where
they had the plexi glass and they had
servers behind you but you could still
go through as many times as you want
and get as much as you want but it kept
it hands-free and i really like that
idea
at south point casino food operations
director michael kennedy says the garden
buffet is not going away
buffets of the past where guests just
walked up and grabbed utensils
themselves
no longer the case we have dedicated
staff who will serve
anything you like from behind our buffet
line they'll serve it safely
we get calls every day to make sure our
buffet is still open and we're thankful
it is we're doing it safely and as for
southport garden buffet here they are
limited hours that that's what they have
but they plan to expand those hours
in the next month now we posted a poll
on twitter to see if you all
wanted the face to come back if you guys
were interested in that and 67 percent
of you said
yes bring them back very interesting
reporting live madison kimbrough
8 news now